you
you
um
okay
so
she's
oh
okay
foreign
okay
general layers
two minute warning
um
oh
okay
uh
yes
for sure
yes
okay
hello everyone this is a historic day
and i have here with me senior advisor
jared kushner
ambassador robert o'brien they're going
to summarize the history that was made
today and take a few of your questions
we also have special representative avi
berkowitz here
and special envoy to iran brian hook who
will be in attendance
thank you kelly and thank you all for
being here i want to start today by
congratulating
the people of israel and the people of
the united arab emirates
today is a historic breakthrough and a
great day for peace
i also want to congratulate president
trump on this milestone he worked very
hard on this with his team
we worked with prime minister netanyahu
and the crown prince mohammed bin zayed
who really are two visionary leaders who
made a big step forward today
to really change the region the last
time we had an agreement like this in
the region was 1994 when israel
made an agreement with the kingdom of
jordan which stopped aggression and
helped bring forward peace
over the last 26 years there's been a
lot of developments in the region
some positive but many that have set the
region back
and it has led to lots of lives being
lost
lots of opportunity and hope being
destroyed and
a region that really has had a lot of
problems when president trump came into
office we had a caliphate
for isis in the middle east which was
the size of ohio
we had a lot of instability iran's
aggression was being felt all throughout
the region
a lot of their proxies were very well
funded and causing instability in yemen
and in syria
and in in other places and now we're in
a position
where we've been able to work with our
allies a lot of our allies felt
abandoned
uh president trump's been able to
rebuild those relationships
his first trip as president was to saudi
arabia in may of 2017
where he laid out the problems that were
facing the region
and very clearly articulated that in
order to make
progress we'd all have to work together
around common goals and we'd have to
acknowledge
uh historic differences in historic
conflicts but we can't
let those conflicts hold us back
president trump's leadership
the ability to build the relationships
with the leaders in the region
people were modernizing their society
and realizing that we needed a new
paradigm
on president trump's visit to saudi
arabia we made an agreement with a lot
of these countries that we're going to
start a counter-terror finance
center and since then we've worked to
limit the amount of funding that's gone
to
extremist groups we worked with saudi
arabia which is the custodian of the two
holy sites
and we worked with them to do a counter
center counter extremism center to
combat online extremism
and that's made a big difference because
you can't solve the short-term problem
without taking on the long-term fight
we've seen saudi arabia make a lot of
modernizations over the last years
giving more rights to women and taking
steps in the right direction which have
been very positive
and now today's breakthrough really
allows us to go forward
uh to give you a little bit of
background on this deal uh this is
something that's been in discussions now
for over a year and a half
uh we were talking with israel we were
talking with united arab emirates about
moving forward
uh obviously because of the israeli
elections and because of some other
things that were happening in the region
this is something that was talked about
but never really got to the right
place for it to happen as you know it
deals deals happen when deals are ready
and peace deals are very rare and very
historic and there's a lot of
reasons why people would be held back
from moving forward
what we saw was when the president
rolled out his vision for peace which we
worked very hard on for a couple of
years to really try to understand the
issues in the region between the
israelis the palestinians
he put forward 180 pages of detail on
how we can
address the issues of the past but also
figure out how to move forward
during that acknowledgement president
trump was able to get israel to agree to
have a
two-state solution with the palestinians
and for the first time in history to
agree to a map that outlined
the territory that they would be willing
to to work with
in order to see that happen that showed
a lot of people in the region that
israel was serious about really moving
forward and making peace and also showed
them that president trump's leadership
and diplomacy could make things happen
that hadn't happened previously
what happened is as israel was
discussing with us
providing taking israeli law
and sovereignty to areas of the west
bank and applying it
we were having these discussions and
over the last six weeks the discussions
between uae and israel started
accelerating
around this being a potential different
path we all saw ambassador oteva's
op-ed that came out that said that he
thought applying israeli sovereignty to
this
to these areas would be detrimental to
the region and
a new course a new option was created
that was discussed that ultimately both
countries thought was a much more viable
option to go forward
uh israel's agreed to suspend those
efforts at this time and as a result
we're going to focus
on bringing these two countries together
this is really a historic breakthrough
and it shows that president trump's
leadership from the riyadh speech till
today
you see a much different middle east
than what he inherited and hopefully
there's a lot more good things to come
this is an icebreaker between these two
countries this is the first
arab country to normalize relations with
israel in a long time
uh 26 years since jordan and what we're
going to hopefully see from there
is more countries start to do the same
the final thing i'll just say is that
uh here in america the biggest threat
that we saw in
the last campaign was uh really two
things
one was isis the caliphate was growing
we were seeing journalists being
beheaded we were seeing people
burnt in cages and the threat of isis
was something that
was very scary to a lot of americans and
needed to be stopped
the instability was providing a place
for extremists to
to plan attacks to plan all kinds of
terrible things
and the extremists were trying to
radicalize the next generation
one of the biggest excuses that
extremists use
to radicalize the next generation is the
mosque and the al-aqsa mosque in saying
that
it's it's it's it's being threatened and
and the fact that muslims aren't able to
pray there
this deal will allow for flights from
dubai and abu dhabi to tel aviv
which will allow muslims a real entree
to come and visit israel peacefully and
to come and pray at the mosque with
whatever frequency they deem appropriate
this is a big breakthrough as people go
there and pray and see that this is
available they'll share it with their
friends and they'll
share the experiences they'll share
pictures of it on instagram and facebook
and twitter
and people throughout the world will see
that the mosque is safe and that
that all people are welcome there so
this is a really great step forward for
the region a great step forward for the
country
and a great step forward for the world
and again i just want to really
complement
the three leaders who worked very hard
to make the possible
prime minister netanyahu of israel the
crown prince mohammed bin zayed of abu
dhabi
and president trump here in america
thank you
so thank you to uh jared for that uh
that summary and it's uh
it's been extraordinary work by a number
of fine diplomats
uh working under president trump's
leadership to
arrive at today's outcome uh jared
kushner has been at the forefront of
those efforts avi
uh brian hook and others have uh have
put in just
just tremendous work uh under the
president's direction
uh to get where we are here today and i
i know jared you're not a you don't have
a diplomat titled ambassador title but
we don't have a finer ambassador
uh especially in the region than uh
advisor kushner so
i thank you for those uh those remarks
and for the really incredible effort
i want to start by congratulating today
the president united states
the prime minister of israel bibi
netanyahu and
crown prince mohammed bin zayed this is
a remarkable achievement
and they've been the achievement is now
will now be known
in history is the abraham accords or the
ibrahim accords and
the muslim countries or the avraham
accords in
israel it's something very special it's
something that doesn't happen very often
very few of my predecessors his national
security advisor
have been able to come to this podium to
announce a peace deal in the middle east
it's a it's a very rare thing
uh as i said earlier in the oval office
today
the president is going to be known uh in
history
as one of the the change makers and one
of the
the remarkable leaders in the middle
east and that's not something that you
may have thought of when he came into
office
but one of his very first steps was
repairing our relationship with israel
which had been badly damaged especially
in the last
month of the prior administration the
president did something that was unheard
of uh
many presidential candidates going back
two decades had promised if
they were elected they would move the
united states embassy in israel from tel
aviv to jerusalem
president trump had the courage to do it
and he developed a
wonderful credibility and a reservoir of
goodwill in israel
he recognized the goal on heights as
being israeli territory and
uh and took those away from a very uh
uh what could have been a very
destabilized situation that we've seen
develop in syria
he destroyed the physical caliphate of
isis which
jared had said it was the size of ohio
it's it was it stretched across the
middle east
and terror arraigned because of the
caliphate
he brought justice to al baghdadi who
had
killed so many americans sotloff and
mueller and kasich
and foley uh he'd put maximum pressure
on iran and and cut off much of the
terrorist funding that was going to
proxy wars in yemen in hezbollah
in lebanon in syria uh and throughout
the region
and today uh we have the the abraham
accords
and he's brought peace to uh the middle
east at least peace between the uae
and israel and what i have said is the
president
is often known as the greatest deal
maker and he wrote the book the art of
the deal and he's considered a great
great deal maker
which he is but i think history is going
to remember
the president for being a great
peacemaker he brought peace to israel
and the uae uh he uh as as signed a
as his diplomats signed a historical
court in afghanistan
i want to remind people that we haven't
had an american casualty in combat in
afghanistan since february 29th
uh he used his uh offices
and his uh his pressure to stop idlib
from being overrun
in syria and and brought a uh a
cease-fire agreement when
when turkey had invaded uh northern
syria uh a lot of people said that when
he came into office that there would be
war
in north korea but through personal
diplomacy his uh
has kept that situation from from
turning into a kinetic
uh uh event so
it's really remarkable i think when you
when you step back and take a look at
what this president has done on the
peace front
uh and and it wouldn't surprise me it'll
take some time in this environment but
it wouldn't surprise me
if the president's eventually nominated
for a nobel prize for the time that
this today's work is an example uh
of why he would be uh rightly considered
and should be a front runner for the
nobel peace prize
so i also want to complement the
courageousness
of mohammed bin zayed the crown prince
you know there have been two other great
arab leaders king hussein in my lifetime
king hussein and anwar sadat
who made peace with israel and now
mohammed bin zayed
enters that pantheon of of great
courageous arab leaders
and i want to compliment president prime
minister netanyahu
in israel who was under tremendous
pressure to extend the israeli law and
sovereignty
to uh portions of the country but is uh
has stepped up against that political
pressure to make peace something that
may have been politically popular
but he he put the interest of his
country and his people first and so
i think we've got some very courageous
leaders uh that worked with the
president
uh to come today today's uh tremendous
historic accord
stepping back from what does this mean
beyond the historic
idea of a major arab country making
peace with israel
uh all these years after 1948 it makes
sense
on so many different level levels uh the
uae and israel are both
capable security partners of the united
states and close
uh close partners of ours in the region
standing up to iran
standing up to islamic extremism uh
that them the the peace agreement
between these two countries will
encourage and foster cooperation uh in
in those efforts
these are very innovative countries uh
israel is uh
it's called the startup nation and for
those of you who've been there it's you
feel like you're driving through palo
alto
through half the country uh the uae is
also a very innovative country
putting those two nations together is
going to create a
dynamic of innovation and creativity uh
in the region and the
both countries are populated by
incredibly dynamic people
there are tremendous opportunities that
are going to arise from this agreement
jared talked about the idea of arab
pilgrims and muslim pilgrims
going to the al-aqsa mosque going up to
the mount and having the opportunity
to pray in peace uh in israel uh the
you know as you know the president has
made religious freedom especially
religious freedom in the middle east
a center point a centerpiece of his
foreign policy
and this is a great step towards uh
fulfilling the idea that the three great
faiths that came from
uh the holy city christianity judaism
and and
and islam uh will be able to pray and uh
and interact peaceably together in
in that beautiful city of jerusalem
tourism
with abu dhabi and dubai and the other
emirates have become
meccas for tourism especially before the
the chinese virus the covet virus
uh israel is a is a great uh land for
tourism
uh that'll expand trade between the uae
and israel which both have
uh incredible economies and again as we
as we recover from covid
uh this agreement will help the
economies of those countries and the
countries in the region
expand and i think you're going to see
an increase in jobs in all three
countries as a result of these accords
uh with respect to the peace process
overall
we've got a great team uh that team is
gonna be fanning out we're gonna be on
the work in the phones
uh we're gonna be in the region and uh
we believe that there are other
countries waiting in the wings
that are gonna watch and and see how uh
the the tremendous response to the
courage of prime minister netanyahu and
the crown prince uh have been received
by their people
and by the world i mean i've already
been on the phone with a number of
european counterparts
who have called to congratulate us uh
for our role in
in this accord but who are some of whom
are astounded that this took place
and uh and we also think that this could
lead to a great deal
for the palestinian people uh that it's
it's a people
the president the united states
president trump has not forgotten and
he's endorsed a two-state solution he
wants to see the
the palestinian people in a prosperous
country of their own
and uh the groundwork has been laid for
that so i think uh
we'll be working very hard on those
efforts in the uh uh in the coming uh
months and uh and year so again today is
a great day it's a great day for the
people of the uae it's a great day for
the people of israel for their leaders
and it's also a great day for the united
states of america as we uh
played a role that we've traditionally
played throughout the world and in
coming in to mediate
in difficult situations and achieve
peace and uh and achieve prosperity for
our friends and and neighbors and
uh and again i'm honored to be a part of
the president's team on this
and uh and again we'll end with uh
congratulations to the president for his
leadership and again to uh prime
minister netanyahu
and uh crown prince mohammed bin zayed
thank you very much
start with steve israel to suspend
its uh annexation plan on the west bank
so
the suspension will last it's going to
take a while for these agreements to get
fully enforced and to go and i think
that
right now the focus that israel is going
to be applying is towards
building this relationship the
opportunities that are now created
because of this from an investment point
of view from an innovation point of view
from a health point of view from a
tourism point of view
and most importantly to both countries
from a security point of view
are very robust and i do believe that
for the foreseeable future
you're going to see both countries
focusing on that i also think that
israel
sees a lot of exciting opportunity in
doing what's being done today
with other arab and muslim countries as
well so that's really going to be the
focus
as to where we're going to be working
with them and you know one thing i also
want to do is acknowledge the tremendous
team that's worked on this to date
obviously secretary pompeo has been
leading the efforts the vice president's
been very supportive
and then obviously avi berkowitz and
brian hook
have been just tremendous along the way
both to get to today and also
in the steps that will likely come
forward
this is already you guys are touting
this as a good step forward but the
palestinian officials are already out
criticizing it
um if they aren't on board how is this a
good piece deal right now right so look
we
they have a fairly predictable response
that we've science seen time and time
again to
all types of things that help make their
people's lives better
let's just focus on the facts of what's
happening and let's focus on how to push
things forward we laid out
a 180 page very detailed plan that we
got israel to agree to negotiate on the
basis of
that invest 50 billion dollars into
their economy that allows them to double
their gdp
over 10 years that can create a million
new jobs help their people have a much
better standard of life
we also got israel to agree to have them
have self-determination
have a secure environment and then in
addition to that
figure out how to create the right land
uh the right land
uh outcome where we can go forward so
look i think that a lot of people in the
region are seeing that
uh we can't wait for the palestinian
leadership to try and
uh resolve this every country is gonna
do what's in their best interests what's
in the region's best interests
and we have big problems in the world
and we can't be stuck in the past we
have to be moving forward now
i will just say that a big part of what
motivated the uae to move forward at
this time
and take the risk that they're taking is
the notion that they didn't want to see
israel take the provocative action of
applying sovereignty to areas of the
west bank
which hopefully allows more space to the
palestinian leadership
to come to the table and make a deal so
i don't know if it will happen
tomorrow i don't know if it'll happen
next month i don't know if it'll happen
next year
but at some point always learn with
deals that there's a thing called
gravity
and uh right now you're in a situation
where israel has
said that they're open to making peace a
lot of people in the region have
supported the vision that the president
laid out
one thing you've seen with the president
he's a deal-making president right and
part of being a deal maker is not always
showing your cards
again we were able to hold this quiet
until this morning when we announced it
the president's had a very robust
strategy for the middle east that we've
been executing piece by piece day by day
and we've seen things have been getting
better problems have been getting
resolved
the president's been taking things off
the table uh you know slaughtering
sacred cows that were holding people
back and so
if you kind of look at the snapshot
today and you look back at the snapshot
of where the president was when he
started you have a much different middle
east and that's not by accident so
i believe over time we're going to
continue to ask ourselves two questions
with that conflict number one is are we
doing things that allow israel to
be more secure versus less secure for
the israeli people that's america's
strongest ally in the region
with this step actually uae joins a very
exclusive club and
becomes you know really one of america's
closest allies in the region
and then number two is are we taking
steps that allow the palestinian people
to live a better life and so you know
there's a lot of people who find
historical traps where they can find
excuses not to move forward
uh but president trump is focused on
creating a bright future
focused on progress and making people's
lives better so
uh i will just say today that this is a
big breakthrough this is something
that's that's public
uh we have a lot of things that are
happening privately right now that are
quite excited
and i do believe again that over the
next years if the president is able to
keep going forward
uh you're going to see some historic
changes in the region that will make
uh really make the world a much safer
and better place
thank you jared appreciate it i just
actually when i ask you uh
advisor o'brien uh you mentioned anwar
sadat and i'm just curious
do you see or envisioned sort of uh
a sadat uh megan carter
picture a moment like that for the
leaders because that's something i think
people remember
i want to say it was 79 but going all
the way back then right
no i think we will have a uh formal
signing ceremony
at the white house and we'll have to see
who comes from the various countries but
i would expect that uh prime minister
netanyahu will be here and either uh
the crown prince or one of his uh one of
the other princes would uh would likely
be here in washington
and i think it'll be a great day and and
really
i i as you know i normally don't talk
about uh things that uh
that were said on presidential phone
calls but one of the one of the leaders
said that we've had a tough 2020
and and this is like the best news of
the year it really is good news it's a
great news story for the american people
and it's been great to see the
how the press has reacted in a somewhat
polarized time i think this is one of
those stories that
everybody regardless of your political
uh uh stripes are on that sort of thing
everybody's excited about the fact that
an arab a muslim arab government is
making peace with israel
big day and we'd love to host them here
at the white house i think the president
would
very much like to host them and so i
think we'll have an event at some point
in the not too distant future
i could follow up on something that you
mentioned earlier you talked about
visionary leadership not just in the
region but to
in general including the president to
make something like this happen
he seemed actually fairly positive
albeit maybe cryptically
that maybe something soon could happen
again to keep this inertia going
to perhaps another country is it your
sense that
yes this er there's a good chance that
we could have a similar announcement
here in the next say 90 days 80 days
i do think there's a very good chance
now one thing i'll say about the
president is that
one of the things you see in great
leaders is a sense of optimism and the
president
is is is a great leader for the country
because he always wants to put forward a
positive front and
get people to do more than they're
capable of doing and help people achieve
things
that people don't think is possible and
so his optimism is one of his great
traits as a leader
i will say here that we have had several
discussions
obviously we kind of stopped those
discussions because this one
looked like it was going and it was very
important to the united arab emirates to
be the first uh they wanted to make
history
and do it uh but we do have several more
that we've had discussions with and now
uh we'll continue those discussions to
see if we can continue to move forward
more
look at the end of the day it's an
inevitability right people in the world
want to move forward the middle east has
to stand on its own two feet
we have some great allies there we'll
continue to to work with them and help
them but we'd like to see a security
architecture
and an economic architecture there where
people have the safety and ability
to live a better life to have jobs to
have prosperity
and people need to believe that their
children could have a better life than
they
can and once that happens people will
choose a job over
uh over over some of the other uh less
good areas that they're being tempted to
go to by the
extremists thank you a couple of
questions
first you mentioned the flights can you
tell us how quickly you expect to
actually see
those flights begin embassies to open up
and to what extent is this strategy in
part
strategy and hope that iran will be
further isolated
i think iran is iran if they want to
move forward uh again the president's
been very clear he's not going to pay
for a meeting but
he's always happy to talk to people and
that's part of him being a deal maker
and that's why
again he was able to make this deal he
was able to make the deal for the opec
plus he was able to make the u.s mexico
uh canada deal who's made make the japan
trade deal the korea deal
we were able to get the the fifa 2026
the olympics 2028 the president's a deal
maker so he'll always be flexible
i do think though seeing the two best uh
two of the best militaries in the region
come together
uh should be something that people take
note of because it shows that
again people are figuring out how they
can optimize and i do think that iran
has benefited from
kind of dividing and conquering through
their proxies they've tried to create
instability
and they've they've tried to have the
middle east divided which is why they've
always
taken advantage of the palestinian issue
and uh and they've tried to stoke fear
around that issue and they've used it to
keep people from joining together with
israel
you know no israelis ever killed an
emirati right there there there's not
um that hatred between the peoples which
is why there's no sense so
i do believe uh that we will start
seeing interactions very quickly and
that both countries are very motivated
both
from an economic point of view from a
tourism point of view from a health
point of view from the technology point
of view
to start moving forward quite quickly
very very quickly
you've been in the headlines recently
just to give you the opportunity to
respond
can you tell us why you were meeting
with kanye west did you discuss the
election at all in any capacity
so kanye's been a friend of mine for i
know about 10 years and
you know we talk every now and then
about different things and we both
happen to be in colorado
and so we we got together and we had a
great discussion about a lot of things
he has some great ideas for
uh for for for what he'd like to see
happen in the country and
and that's why he has the candidacy that
he's been doing
uh but again there's a lot of issues
that the president's champion that he
admires
and uh and it was just great to have a
friendly discussion thank you
just to follow up on steve's question
netanyahu just did a live address
tonight and he said we received a
request to wait temporarily on
annexation from president trump
is that it's a temporary postponement it
is not removed from the table i'm
telling you that
so how long is temporary because you
said it could be a long time and did you
get guarantees that they will
adhere to that somewhere between a long
time and a short time
that's what temporary means but that's
important for them to know how long
temporary is he's saying it's not off
the table it's not canceled it's only
being postponed
look our discussions with the prime
minister have been very extensive
over the last three and a half years we
have a lot of trust between israel and
america
we've done a lot of historic things
together the people of israel trust
president trump to make the right
decisions
that are in the best interests of
israel's security and prosperity and
obviously prime minister netanyahu
and president trump have a very close
relationship i believe that they will
not take action
uh to move forward unless we have an
understanding between america and israel
that it's the right action at the right
time
and again you know it's not like a
binary thing to move forward or not
there's a lot of details there's a lot
of things that need to be considered
and we had a lot of those discussions
over the coming months and then
obviously put those discussions on hold
as this came about so i imagine at some
point in the future this is something
that will be discussed but
today is a great day this is a big
breakthrough this is a game changer
for israel it's a game changer for the
middle east and it's a game changer for
the world so
i think for the time being people are
gonna focus on that and focus how to
optimize from that tremendous
opportunity
we had a general discussion more about
policy
let me ask you about a different deal
one here in washington democrats
republicans are two and a half trillion
dollars apart
it seems from your view do you believe
it's possible right now
of a phase four deal coming together
working with president trump for the
last five years on the campaign and
through government
i would just say that with president
trump anything's possible so
uh you never know the president's
accomplished a lot of things that people
thought would never be accomplished and
uh
but to comment specifically on the deal
i'll leave that up to the negotiators
since we seem to have exhausted
questions on this topic i'm going to
pass it back to hillary
clinton thank you
earlier this is part of the job the
a administration is council resolution
to extend the arms embargo on iran it's
not shorter
it's worth a lot of tough language on
iran but still
there's still a danger of veto from
russia and china
so some observers are saying that the
administration is risking
losing faith if you can't get support
over this deal can you comment on that
well the first thing is we're always
going to do the administration's
obviously the right thing and president
trump is always going to do the right
thing
uh whether it's losing face or there's a
russian veto or a chinese veto if the
chinese or the russians
veto the continuation of the arms
embargo i want to start sending arms
to iran and destabilizing the region
that's on them and
that's not on us so we're always going
to take the position the right position
and not worry about uh what the russians
or what the chinese might do at the u.n
if we did that
uh we worried about that all the time we
would get nothing done at the un
uh we also have other tools that we'll
use to deal with iran to make sure that
that arms don't flow into iran that
there's not further destabilization of
the region
they're tools that we can use
diplomatically and and there are other
tools that we have and uh
nobody in the region wants to see iran
on the receiving end of a bunch of
russian migs or
chinese missiles or chinese drones uh
the region's made that very clear
uh we've made that very clear uh
israel's made that very clear so
i i don't think that's in the interest
of anyone in the world it's not in the
interest of
of global uh peace and security and
prosperity
uh so we're gonna continue to prosecute
our case at the u.n and we're gonna hope
for the best i hope the russians and the
chinese
do the right thing uh they should do the
right thing and
uh and if they don't do the right thing
uh well we we've got
uh we've got backup steps that we'll
take
snapback certainly one of the tools that
we could use and uh
and uh that's something we're looking at
very closely and uh i wouldn't say
look what we're focused on right now is
the vote to extend the arms embargo we'd
like a clean roll over the arms embargo
we'd like to see our allies get behind
it
we'd like to see the russians and
chinese get behind it i just can't
imagine
any leader anywhere in the world who
thinks it's a good idea to put advanced
armaments in the hands of the ayatollah
and his regime
especially in today's middle east i mean
that just makes zero sense whatsoever
so so hopefully the countries at the un
security council will do the right thing
they'll roll over the arms embargo and
keep it in place
but if that doesn't happen uh we've got
we'll we'll take steps
necessary and one of those steps could
be it could be snapback
thank you
thank you very much to senior advisor
jared kushner and ambassador o'brien and
i will take a few of your questions
on other matters you have any
yes oh thank you kaylee um the president
has written a
miranda to give five states 100
of uh reimbursement for the national
guard costs dealing with the coronavirus
a number of governors are trying to get
on that list too including nevada
governor steve sissel act
um have you had a chance to set up a
time for them to talk
and the national governors association
say that uh
says that the criteria for being one of
those states that gets 100
not 75 percent aren't clear can you tell
me
how do you make the cut where you're 100
not 75
so first let me note that in march
president trump became the first
president to authorize
use of the national guard under title 32
status with 100
cost share the president supports the
men and women of our national guard
this is a rarely used tool but the
president was willing to take this
decisive action
uh 75 of the cost share is still giving
states tremendous
unprecedented support um and states can
utilize their coronavirus relief fund
dollars to cover the remaining 25
if they need to um specifically a few
states made direct cases to the
president and he obliged to support them
at 100 but i won't go state by state as
to where things stand
can you explain why some states were yes
yesterday what did he mean by when he
said he was going to terminate
the payroll tax and a secondary question
if he's re-elected what should americans
believe about his commitment to social
security
yeah he has unwavering commitment to
social security making sure that it is
fully funded and that our seniors are
taken care of i've heard him express
that private
privately and publicly a myriad of times
what he was meaning yesterday is that he
wants permanent forgiveness of the
deferral he's of course deferred the
payroll tax
uh to the end of the year and he wants
to make that a permanent forgiveness
of the deferral uh come next year
because it's very important for
specifically low and middle income
american since it's a regressive tax
in the long term though does he think
that the payroll tax should go away
um the president's very clear on this
matter that he wants a permanent
forgiveness of the deferral
um that's as far as he's gone and he's
gone um even further to say he's going
to make sure that social security
is fully funded okay
yeah oh the lead and then okay you fell
you voted by the u.s mail the president
has voted by the u.s mail
many of his top people have about that
why is he trying to prevent
ordinary americans from voting by mail
um so
first let me note i've voted absentee
the president's voted absentees
always been for voting absentee for a
reason
what he is not for is mass mail-in
voting or perhaps to make it even
clearer
mass mail out voting where everyone on
the voting rolls is mailed
out a ballot um voting rolls in los
angeles county for example you have
percent of the county registered to vote
how does that even make sense it doesn't
and that would mean that in the least
seventeen percent of the ballots
floating around
would be subject to potential fraud so
that's what the president is standing
firmly against
uh but he has always been for absentee
for a reason
okay we learned today that still roughly
15 and a half million americans
are without a job nancy pelosi spoke
yesterday
with the treasury secretary seemingly
there was no progress on that call or
the 15 and a half million americans and
millions others who could absolutely
care less about the politics of it all
what would you tell them is coming next
considering that it seems as if
nothing is moving policy wise going
forward yeah what i would say is this
you know secretary mnuchin said
yesterday i am
willing to move forward with legislation
that provides funds to
schools child care food vaccines
hospitals ppp for small businesses
rental assistance broadband airport
state and local government assistance
and liability protection for university
schools and businesses he's been
unmistakable this administration has and
this president has
we're willing to move forward on that
what we're not willing to do uh is
rubber stamp a behemoth
3.4 trillion dollar deal that the
democrats put forward that was
fundamentally unserious that would have
made
ballot harvesting mainstream that was a
democrat wish list
that's what we'll not move forward with
but this president out of
anyone has taken action serious action
on eviction protection
serious action on unemployment insurance
on a payroll tax cut
student loan forgiveness in his
executive capacity and what i would say
the state of things now is you know you
have nancy pelosi saying we were willing
to come down a trillion if they came up
a trillion well it's fundamentally
unserious because the democrats the
chief of staff has told me wouldn't even
tell us
uh what they would take out of the 1
trillion so they said we'd come down a
trillion but wouldn't list out the
things that they would take out
of their democrat wish list so nancy
pelosi needs to come back from recess
and negotiate because the american
people deserve better
conservatives who have made the argument
that three trillion dollars give or take
has already been spent and no more needs
to be spent
if there isn't a deal that is viable is
the white house of the position that
since three trillion has been spent it's
okay we don't need to spend any more so
the president
is all about what is best for america's
families he wants to see funding for our
schools
direct payments to americans he's
protected the american people in every
way he can in his executive capacity
but as you noted in terms of the fiscal
cost of things and the height of
in the height of this when the economy
was shut down there was a two trillion
dollar deal
negotiated uh next after that when the
economy was reopened it was a one
trillion dollar deal so for the
democrats to say we want
more than what we even negotiated and
passed during an economic shutdown and
to say we need 3.4 trillion
it's really an unserious proposal kevin
thank you
your reaction to unemployment claims
dipping below a million
1.7 1.7 million new jobs as well
and blue state governors are
politicizing school closures
says the president what did he mean by
that yeah what he means by that is that
when you look around the world many
countries in the western world have
opened their schools
and that we as the united states can do
the same we can find a way the president
the white house has released guidance as
to how to make that happen
i mean he doesn't want a child a
decision that is so important for our
children
to be politicized because he believes
that it's in the public health interest
of the child
uh to be back in school and i've listed
out for you um all the reasons for that
previously
i mean what was your first question yes
dipping below a million
uh how surprised are you that that's the
figure and
the direction we're going i'm not
surprised because under this president
he was
the great jobs president once brought us
the greatest economy in modern history
once and he'll do it again and this is
more evidence of that to see
unemployment claims dip below
a million coming on the backs of a july
jobs report that exceeded expectations
and of course the
two blockbuster jobs reports before that
it goes in line with the manufacturing
ism
good numbers that we saw on many other
metrics this is the president who's
already
making sure we have an economic rebound
that outpaces
europe and other countries
has the president been briefed on the
russian coronavirus vaccine
does he think it's a workable vaccine
the president has been
briefed on that he's also been briefed
on our own vaccine progress
on one thing to note and i believe dr
fauci made this point
our vaccines go through rigorous phase 3
clinical trial where we have 30
000 individuals that we test to make
sure it's perfectly healthy and moving
forward so
that's the kind of standard we have for
american vaccines and it's important
that we do that but we do
i think that we'll have a vaccine by the
end of the year and the president in
advance of that is
manufacturing hundreds of millions of
doses of these vaccines in anticipation
of one being
thank you haley um going back to iran
and russia
as geopolitical actors in the middle
east they've been well springs of
instability there as we discussed but
how confident is this white house that
iran and russia are finally going to be
placed in their respective lanes
in the advent of this deal and deals to
come
um well look we believe um that there's
a big contrast here um and where this
administration stands and the previous
administration and when you look at the
um excuse me the obama biden
administration they cozied up to
america's enemies uh the iran deal
was egregious we know that there were
cash payouts to iran
and what this president has done is
diametrically opposite
working with our allies working with
israel negotiating a historic peace
agreement
like hasn't been seen in a quarter of a
century so when you work with our allies
when you engage in diplomacy
we have a great deal maker as president
uh you get deals like what we saw today
and it's stark contrast to what we saw
from the previous administration yes
does the president share former vice
president biden's view that annexation
would virtually end any chance at a
two-state solution that would secure
israel's future as a jewish and
democratic state and uphold the rights
of palestinians to have seen it there
yes so um i'm not going to go any
further into
the state of middle east peace i'd refer
you to nsc on that but today we're
focusing on the historic agreement
that's been made yes
is was the president aware about these
2000 letters
between him and chairman kim that
apparently going to be published in the
new bob woodward book did he sign off on
that
um i haven't even looked into that or
spoken to them about that we're focused
today
on providing relief to the american
people and the historic deal mario
thank you kelly will the president's
executive order on wechat block uh
apple from distributing that app on
their platform
and if so what does the administration
say about concerns that it could be
kneecapping an american company and
diminishing its uh competitiveness
so the um only remarks i have for you
today on tick tock and wechat are this
the president he signed those two
executive orders
exercising his authority under the
international emergency economic powers
act
to address the threats posed by tick
tock and wechat
the administration is committed to
protecting the american people from all
cyber threats and these apps collect
significant amounts of private data
on users and such information can be
accessed and used by the prc
and tick tock has a documented history
of censoring free speech to conform to
ccp propaganda
and we take the data of americans very
seriously
one other thing i wanted to clear up is
that speaker pelosi has been
fundamentally on serious in these
negotiations and engaging in blatant
partisanship
one thing she said recently is that she
needs three point billion
3.5 billion dollars with a b for
election
funding that is a fundame fundamentally
unserious ask for this reason
i talked to the office of management and
budget they said states have been given
over 1.2
billion dollars in election assistance
grants since fiscal year 2018 and we
estimate that they've spent
less than a sixth of that funding in
these three years
and still have over one billion of those
funds sitting around
right now that have not been spent so we
encourage
for speaker pelosi to follow in the
footsteps of the suggestion of
congressman ro khanna of her own party
who said i think congress should be in
session i think it's absurd
for congress to be going on a break
during a pandemic and a national crisis
i can tell you one person who hasn't
been on a break
it's this president providing relief for
the american people thank you and he'll
be out here at 5 30. thanks so
question much questions
you